hi guys it's ria i'm a tasty producer
right now i'm in japan and one thing you
might notice in japan is there a lot of
convenience stores
and surprisingly food is so good and one
of the most popular item is
egg salad sandwich today i'm going to
try to make egg salad sandwich better
than 7-eleven one
[Music]
all right let's get started so i'm going
to start with making bread because it
takes time we have to prove three times
and i wanted to make chocobo which is
japanese like bread it's like everyday
bread by the way this recipe was
developed by sako
i have bread flour
so first you're going to mix sugar and
salt and mix very well make a well and
then add water milk and yeast and you're
gonna just like mix it so once it become
like in a messy bowl
uh you're going to start kneading so
you're kind of like kneading against the
board like stretching
and
you want to knead until it doesn't
sticky and it's kind of elastic ball
i don't remember how many chocolate i
ate in my life it's almost like every
day so
though it's nice and bouncy so i'm going
to incorporate butter
in here asmr
okay so i think we are done
the indicator is the dough it's kind of
shiny and elastic now
so i have a running joke i have the
editor person put eyeball around here
and this is my dobie and we are going to
put this in a bowl and put the plastic
and i'm going to proof it over there
while we are waiting the dough is
proofing we are going to make hot boiled
egg so water is boiling so i'm going to
drop egg slowly so it doesn't break very
gentle for 12 minutes
i feel like egg sandwich is very staple
sandwich in japan so like i remember
having egg salad sandwich for my lunch
so right after you boil egg you want to
drop into cold water or like ice water
so you can um
do you say the shell
so you can peel the egg
also if the
egg is super fresh it's difficult to
peel
oh
very satisfying isn't it
look
so smooth
big b
so
my eggs are peeled i'm going to go next
step which is separating egg yolk and
egg whites i'm gonna chop everything and
i will decide how much i want to
incorporate i feel like this makes one
like half sandwich
but it's five eggs
that scares me
so
now you're going to mix ingredients
sugar
so
so this is very crucial secret
ingredients it's japanese qp mayonnaise
cupid mayonnaise makes
everything taste better you cannot use
any other mayonnaise
it's good but um i
want to make it as close as it gets
texture is very similar i think we are
there for this video i think we only
need a half amount of egg whites it's a
yolk ford egg salad so i'm going to hop
up with plastic and put it in the
refrigerator one hour later
my baby
look at this
so fluffy so it's proofed and i want to
remove the gas in it so you have to
punch it and
kind of release the gas
yeah release the gas and you're going to
form it again
and we are going to do second proof
close the seam on the bottom
you are going to cover with wet towel
and wait for 20 minutes
now i'm going to shape this dough
do you hear the sound it's almost like
squeaking
in a pain but it's like a you know
growing pain
all right so you want to fold it and
you're going to roll it up and we have a
chakra mold which is like square mold
it's already oiled and before you put in
the mold you want to close the seam and
you're going to put this in
so you kind of like put one side not in
the center put the plastic this is going
to be the last proof before we bake in
the oven which is one hour
all right so this is ready and you want
to drop this
so you kind of kill the little bubble
you kind of want to give a little shock
and then open the lid
oh my god
it looks great
cool it down i'm going to cut this and
we are going to make the sandwich right
so this is the egg salad i made earlier
i think it's a little too much marinade
so i want to add a little bit cream
more than anything i'm so proud of me
making
choc pan
let's see
how it tastes
so today i made from scratch and give me
honest opinion okay here we go
the bread is exactly the same yay like i
couldn't see no difference in the bread
um
[Music]
[Music]
i feel
it's not as sweet
as
like the comedy one
[Music]
i do like it i like how creamy it is but
i feel like this one might be a little
bit more flavorful i'm sorry
my feeling it's hard
i feel it's because it's much sweeter
it has like a stronger taste to it
[Laughter]
um
[Music]
most likely you don't have access to buy
711 egg salad sandwich so this is how
you can make it at home this one is
relatively easy it's very cheap to make
i encourage you to make it a home
because it's delicious too if you visit
japan you can find a lot of different
convenience store and each convenience
store have their own egg salad sandwich
so when you visit japan
go to any convenience store
pick one and pick your favorite
[Music]
[Music]
you